si tous les conducteurs prenait le
chemin le plus rapide il est évident que
construire de nouvelles routes ne
pourrait que fluidifier le trafic
et bien c'est pour toutes ces évidences
en réalité complètement fausse que
j'adore les mathématiques
sans elle nous pourrions contempler ces
curiosités sans elles nous serions
prisonniers de notre intuition
j'aime les maths parce que c'est le
langage champlain notre univers en tant
que physicien mon but est de comprendre
et donc de traduire ce que l'univers me
raconte
et pour ça j'ai besoin des maths c'est
un outil essentiel parfois complexes
mais nécessaire j'aime les maths parce
que même si elles paraissent compliqués
à apprendre et à comprendre pendant
toute notre scolarité
au final tout le monde finit par les
utiliser tous les jours intuitivement
est sans même s'en rendre compte
j'ai bien compris que pour aborder le
monde avec plus de finesse qu'un homme
préhistorique
il me faut utiliser les maths se
contenter d'utiliser des mots pour
décrire notre univers notre quotidien
c'est juste devenu dépassé et inefficace
ce que j'aime dans les mathématiques
c'est leur densité leur concision il ya
un exemple que j'aime particulièrement
car c'est généralement pas le premier
qui vient à l'esprit quand on pense aux
mathématiques c'est les automates
cellulaires ou quelques cases sur une
grille et 3 règles permettent d'obtenir
des comportements macroscopique
extrêmement complexe ce que j'aime dans
les maths c'est que ça sert beaucoup
pour l'histoire les dates non seulement
mais aussi beaucoup les statistiques on
s'en sert énormément
et oui c'est primordial pour les
historiens j'aime les maths mais
pourquoi j'aime les maths parce que
c'est le langage dans lequel ces cris la
physique pour devenir prédictifs j'aime
les maths car elles permettent de
comprendre n'importe quoi pour peu qu'on
s'y attarde eu suffisamment cependant on
a aussi la certitude de ne jamais tout
connaître
finalement avec les maths on est sûr
d'avoir toujours de quoi s'occuper
j'aime les maths parce qu'on peut
découvrir des planètes avec et une a été
la première et la dernière je crois
planètes du système solaire forcément
découverte grâce aux mathématiques moi
j'aime les maths c'est parce que comme
le disait un mathématicien russe qui
s'appelle vladimir arnold les
mathématiques c'est de la physique dont
les expériences coûte pas cher j'aime
les maths car elles offrent de la
difficulté facile d'accès quand on
s'ennuie et qu'on veut tester ses
limites intellectuelles une ligne
dénoncé peut suffire à nous tenir en
haleine pendant des années j'aime les
maths
car
même les élites et les énigmes les plus
difficiles celles qui ont occupé pendant
des centaines d'années les esprits les
plus brillantes se trouve dans les
mathématiques
j'aime les maths parce que c'est logique
parce que ces techniques et un peu comme
pour un puzzle quand finalement on à
assembler toutes les pièces et qu'on
obtient la réponse qu'on cherchait eh
ben c'est quand même un sentiment de
satisfaction très très cool
ce que j'aime avec les matches j'aurais
jamais pensé pouvoir dire ça un jour
étant donné le mal que j'ai eu avec l
école il m'a fallu attendre d'aller à
l'université et d'étudier la philosophie
l'histoire des sciences pour les
apprécier ce que j'aime avec les maths
c'est l'universel qui s'insère dans le
particulier de l'histoire des êtres
humains
j'aime les mathématiques parce que si la
vérité la plus pure que je puisse
imaginer savoir l'absence de risque
d'erreur d'une preuve formelle est on ne
peut plus rassurant
j'aime les maths car je les ai toujours
considéré comme une source inépuisable
de castets et de défis à résoudre et je
me suis rendu compte avec le temps de
leur importance au quotidien même pour
une biologiste
j'aime les maths car les aventures que
j'ai vécu et que je vis encore dans
leurs paysages immenses et abstrait me
laisse à chaque fois tout palpitant tout
éblouis et tous rempli de toutes sortes
d'émotions que je ne retrouve nulle part
ailleurs
j'aime les maths parce que tout en étant
la plus rigoureuse c'est aussi la
science la plus libre en ceci que c'est
la seule qui n'est pas contrainte par le
réel n'a pas d'autre objet d'étude que
ce qu'elle se crée elle même à travers
des actions des règles des définitions
les objets mathématiques surgissent de
là comme par magie et ça a quelque chose
de génial et de fou moi j'aime les maths
comme on aime la musique comme on aime
un beau tableau
ou un bon film en faisant ça beau en
fait j'aime les maths parce que c'est
beau j'aime les maths parce que je
trouve ça à la fois complètement
abstrait et terriblement concret au
début on fait des calculs on sait pas
trop à quoi ça sert et quand tout
devient clair c'est un peu comme une
révélation et on se dit ah mais ouais
jeanne et mathématiques comme un peu
qu'on admire quelque chose de lointain
de mystérieux de fascinant je suis à la
fois stupéfaits par la puissance de leur
prédiction est un peu émerveillés par
comme la musique la poésie la musique
qui se cache derrière le fonctionnement
des équations comme les maths
car elle développe notre côté artistique
elle nous permet d touché avec une aux
mains
la perfection et elle nous amène vers
l'éternité
ce que j'aime avec les maths c'est
qu'elles sont structurantes ce que je
veux dire c'est que n'importe quel acte
créatif ou même abstrait comme la
musique un one man show de peinture de
la sculpture tout ça peut être traduit
par des formules mathématiques et c'est
ce qui fait que ça tient debout mais ça
je trouve ça passionnant
j'aime les maths car les maths c'est
magnifique par exemple on peut compter
après l'infini on peut y dupliquer la
matière ou bien on peut trouver des
points d'intersection entre des objets
qui ne se coupe pas rien de tel que les
maths pour assommer l'intuition
j'aime les maths pour ce qu'elle nous
permette de rendre visible ce que
l'essence ne perçoivent pas de dévoiler
des choses lointaine de sont approchés
pour mieux les comprendre de
différencier le moins probable du plus
improbables j'aime les maths
j'aime les gens qui aiment les maths
vaut aussi j'aime à quel point ils sont
curieux rigoureux créatif rêveur est
passionné et j'aime que vous soyez aussi
nombreux à aimer les maths
vous aussi du fond de mon coeur je tiens
à vous dire merci merci de m'avoir suivi
dans les péripéties mathématiques que
l'on a vécu sur cette chaîne et que l'on
continuera à vivre ensemble
merci pour toutes vos interrogations
toutes vos réflexions et tous vos
commentaires bienveillants
merci d'avoir partagé avec moi la joie
de faire des mathématiques
merci merci et encore merci